[Applause]
the world you know no longer exists your
family friends and neighbors are gone
outside horrific zombie-like creatures
roam the streets and if you breathe in
their spores you're one of them
and if that wasn't bad enough human
factions have formed that want you dead
or Worse luckily it's just a fictional
universe of the popular game and now TV
show The Last of Us and this could never
happen right
right could a scenario like this happen
one day what if you became infected and
how would you survive in this new world
this is what if and here's what would
happen if the Last of Us happened in
real life
cordyceps are fungi that can take
control of insects and turn them into
zombies no really it happens when a
Spore lands on the insect and takes root
in its muscles the spores then control
the insect and move it to a new location
where they can reproduce the insect dies
more get infected and the cycle
continues and in The Last of Us these
cordyceps can infect humans producing
mushroom-headed monstrosities known as
clickers oh and you also have supplies
like food and water running at an
all-time low not to mention a complete
societal collapse so how are you gonna
get through this
if we lived in a world where Airborne
spores could infect us the cities would
become the most dangerous places you
could be have a gas mask handy because
subway tunnels underground Pathways and
sewer systems would quickly become a
breeding ground for the infected
those in rural areas or small towns
would have the best chances they'd be
further from ground zero and be able to
respond to protect themselves and this
assumes that the way to get infected is
through spores but even if it is
tendrils like we see in the show the
same rules would apply now if you're in
a colder region like the Arctic you'd be
in luck the spores wouldn't be able to
reproduce or survive due to the cold
weather here is where you would have the
best chance of re-establishing a
civilization however your only enemy in
this world wouldn't just be the fungus
in the Lawless world of The Last of Us
other human beings can't be trusted
blindly scavengers and Raiders could be
waiting to take advantage of you to
steal your resources and your golf clubs
now survivors would be forced to
establish some form of communication
Network to fight each other as our best
chance of fighting off a horde of the
infected as well as Gathering food and
resources is to form groups small
fortified Villages might be built
resembling some form of civilization but
it would never be like it used to
and this is assuming you made it this
far without getting infected but what if
you did happen to breathe in these
spores well hate to break it to you but
you're not going to be immune like Ellie
in this scenario it's likely that as the
fungus attacks your body you'd begin to
feel some symptoms you've probably felt
before a fever abdominal pain weakness
and vomiting are all possible
consequences you might also notice
yourself getting depressed as the
cordyceps could affect your dopamine
levels as time goes on the fungus would
start to take over your nervous system
but it wouldn't happen in a matter of
hours I mean since you're a lot bigger
than an insect it would take months for
the cordyceps to finally take over but
as this is happening the fungus would
grow throughout your arms and legs when
it spreads far enough in your body it
can gain control over you you could try
your best to fight it off but once it's
inside of you there's really nothing you
can do
I mean your brain would still be running
but you wouldn't have control over what
you do with it
yeah after all the Corey sip's primary
purpose is to spread as much as it can
and to do that it would trap you inside
an enclosed area so it can grow spread
through and release more of its spores
hoping to infect others after a couple
of weeks you would die in that spot like
the last of us is shambler
I
hate and now that you're dead the
cordyceps fungus can continue to spread
turning you into what's known as a
fruiting body this is when spores and
fungi would start to come out of you
yeah they've come out of everywhere that
doesn't have any hard bone blocking its
way and the longer you stay this way the
more you'll become a Spore generating
monstrosity
okay but how possible is this really
well The Last of Us poses a theory that
if fungi evolved to withstand higher
temperatures then it could infect humans
and in the show that very thing happens
but How likely is this
well right now the cordyceps fungi need
a temperature between 20 and 30 degrees
Celsius in order to survive lucky for
you the human body temperature is closer
to 37 degrees Celsius meaning that the
cordyceps wouldn't be able to withstand
your body heat well phew
but what if the cordyceps were able to
survive in higher temperatures
well you'd still be fine that's because
our bodies are much more complex than a
simple ant and our immune systems are
quite a bit stronger well great it looks
like you're immune like Ellie after all
yeah you can rest easy knowing you won't
turn into a zombie from these things but
what if instead of turning you into one
there was a full-on zombie apocalypse
Yee well that's a story for another what
if